C'était mieux avant quand il y avait pas Facebook finalement
Au fait, je t'ai pas dit, j'ai une nouvelle copine depuis peu...elle s'appelle Aurélie
Je sais
Enfin, bref, euh, en gros, ce weekend on est allé à la montagne et on a vu des super...
Et tu savais pour ça?!
C'était mieux avant, quand il y avait des films à la télé le soir
maintenant...
[Après les experts à Las Vegas, les experts à Miami, les experts à Manhattan,
tout de suite, dix-sept épisodes des experts sur la lune.]
[Hé Horacio, t'as déjà pété dans ta combinaison?
Ouahh, ça pique le nez!]
C'était mieux quand il y avait que 151 Pokémon!
Ça, c'est un Pokémon.
Ça, c'est des conneries!
Parce que sinon, moi aussi, je prends un animal, je lui rajoute des cornes, des pattes, des ailes,
je lui mets des lettres dans le désordre et ça fait un Pokémon!
Très bien, hein?!
Il est pas mal..hein, il est... Je tiens un truc!
Je crois que je tiens un truc!
Je tiens un truc!
C'était mieux avant, quand il y avait pas internet sur les téléphones...
...surtout en soirée quoi...
Non, mais, sérieux là, c'est quoi ce délire! Il faut faire un truc!
Non, mais, n'importe quoi là!
Tu peux pas venir?!
Ah, c'est dommage, on passe une bonne soirée ici!
D'ac...ok...bisous!
Ah! J'ai un mail...
Mais même dans les jeux vidéo c'était mieux avant!
Avant quand j'achetais un jeu vidéo,  j'étais tout excité...
Yes!!
Et puis il y a maintenant, quoi...
C'était mieux avant, quand il y avait des jouets à monter soi-même dans les Kinder Surprises
Ça, c'était chouette
Parce que maintenant...
Super...
...un petit personnage...
Où vais-je le ranger?
Ah, oui...
C'était mieux avant, quand on payait en francs.
Bonjour, une baguette s'il vous plaît.
[Ça fera trois francs.]
Très bien.
Maintenant...
Bonjour, une baguette s'il vous plaît.
[Ça fera un euro.]
Très bien.
Espèce d'escroc!
[Pardon?!]
De quoi, non, je...rien entendu...je ne sais pas de quoi tu....je sais pas...Allez!
Voilà! Bon, ben, il y a le compte
Connard!
[Quoi?!]
Hein? Rien entendu...je, non...j'ai rien entendu...
Allez! Donne la baguette!
Finalement, je dirais que c'était mieux avant, quand on pouvait voir toutes mes autres vidéos sur Cyprien.fr
et que les gens se partageaient cette vidéo sur Facebook, comme ça :
<<Regarde-là! Vas-y, clique!>>
Ah, non, ça, ça marche toujours!
Ça, c'est toujours d'actualité! Hein, les mecs! Je...
Sous-titrage par @ChezMadameS